Hello, everyone.
Good morning.
Yes, I do not sound like I want to die in Minecraft right now because I had a good night's sleep.
Yay!
Oh, that reminds me.
I need to do my chewable, my vitamin C chewable real quick.
Get that orange, those oranges in my system.
And, yeah, I was, but yes, well, to be fair, I sort of passed out at like 10 p.m.
I was so tired.
I think it's like...
Like, during the Batman stream yesterday, I was yawning a lot.
I think my body, I think it's because, like, I had to wake up early last, yesterday.
Not last night.
I don't remember.
Why was I had to wake up early yesterday?
I don't even remember.
No, I didn't wake up early.
I woke up 1 p.m.
yesterday.
Okay, I don't know.
I was just tired.
My body was just tired.
So I went to bed at, like, 10 p.m.
and then woke up at like uh uh 4 a.m um i know okay that i know it sounds bad but like hear me out uh because i have to upload my waiting room for uh uh habromania and then um i got a i got a dm from my manager and then my manager was like hey whatever you're free we have to go over some sponsor stuff and some business stuff and i was like the only time i was like free technically because um today's like a long ass day for me so i know we have like a like you know this stream then what's gonna happen after that stream a lot of like behind the scenes stuff i have to do after this stream um that's gonna last till like i think like till like 8 p.m so i was like this is the only time.
I was like, dude, my manager, this is the only time.
And so, like, after that, me and my manager, we had to have, like, our little work call.
And, yeah, and then, and then, I went back to sleep.
And here I am.
Here I am.
Yeah, Tokyo is on.
It's now or never.
And then, like,
sidetrack on anything i was like i'm tired i you know like a child's like i'm tired bless this all right that he has to put up with me i want to go back to sleep like a fucking brat and he'd be like you're the one that sidetracked this i'll be like you're supposed to stop me from sidetracking i'm tired
And, yeah, and I still, yeah, so we had a little, we had a little argument being like, handle these Japanese emails.
And he's like, what do you mean?
I don't, I don't speak to, I was like, we have a trust, you deal with it.
We have a translator, you deal with it.
And I'm like, I'm tired.
I want to go to bed.
I was like, I thought we were going to be talking about sponsors.
and he'd be like you're the one that brought up these emails like whatever i'm sleepy now i don't want to go back to sleep so um that was like um our conversation and no i was just cranky i was just really cranky because it was like five in the morning and i thought i just needed to wake up for um to just like you know do my waiting room stuff but i was like you know what i should also handle the business side of things too because he can't approve anything without my approval because of consent like um so it led to all of that and uh i was just really cranky too because like i said i just wanted to go back to bed um and uh and yeah so then i you know got my got my sleep again and And,
you know, walked that.
He didn't take me on the side quest.
And now we're here.
Yay!
But, yes, I was craving Jolly Bees, too.
I don't know.
I woke up and I was like, I want Jolly Bees.
I want Jolly Spaghetti and Jolly Chicken to make me a Jolly Boy.
Yay!
So, I'm glad Jolly Bees is open right now.
So, we might have a little delay as I eat my little Jolly Spaghetti.
Medi-Diggy with a Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
stop fighting thank you for the super chat thank you thank you aphelion thank you for the five gifts of chips thank you thank you you are what do you mean i just want to be a jolly boy um what else what else oh yeah i just wanted to act about this but uh yesterday i um i might have got into like this little rabbit hole of like robot animal spy videos i don't even know how I got there.
I was like binge watching like a couple of like robot spy videos and they're like narrated by David Tennant.
Um for those who don't know he's like the only doctor I respect and doctor who.
Uh and there was one I had to talk to you about this because this is so fucking funny.
Um there are actually two videos where they're like their ones with a monkey and the other one was a gorilla and um so um the girl the monkeys were like I want to take care of this chat because they're all like robots of like babies you know they're like baby robots for the monkey and the um the gorilla so then the other monkeys when they saw the robot monkey they're like i have to take care of this child you know they're like what is this child doing they're all alone where are your parents and so they were trying to like gank the robot off like the branches like off of this like log and stuff that he was like supposed to be like glued to and he's like come with me you and then they one of the monkeys yanked the yanked the robot off of the log and then she dropped it it's not like she just dropped it from you know like the ground she was on a tree and then she dropped a baby robot and then you know the baby robot was just like
and it obviously they all thought it was dead they're like oh no God, I'm burning a child.
And it was like, you know, they literally just like gave these monkeys trauma because it was like, it was like a tribe.
So all the monkeys were surrounding here.
It was like, what did you do, Sharon?
What the fuck did you do?
Because like I saw, I saw the thumbnail and I was like, what the fuck?
And all these monkeys were like green, like having a little funeral.
for the fucking tiny ass robot and i was like oh my god like i i swear to god these monkeys have fucking trauma right now like wait let me show you guys i gotta show you guys the picture i saw this thumbnail i was like oh like that's like that's what the you know they thought that you know they obviously if i see that i'd be like that's a fucking dead monkey and obviously the Like,
oh my god, I killed him.
I killed a child.
So they were all like grieving it and having a little like fucking monkey funeral.
Like, dude, that's so messed up.
I'll show you, I'll give you guys the link so you can watch it on your own time.
There's another one where they had like a, they had like a snake robot and they made it participate in a snake orgy.
It was fun.
But the snake robot was like, was like six times the size of all the others.
snakes but they didn't care they're like let's go have some fun but anyway there was this other um there was this other video on um where um where it was a gorilla it was a gorilla robot and
um and like basically uh one of the child there another this one was a child ran up to the and he was like let's play because like if you beat your chest like you know when adults gorillas beat their chest um it means they want to fight but when like babies like children gorillas beat their chest it means they're like let's play yeah let's play um so the gorilla robot the gorilla robot like knows how to beat their chest and stuff so you know they're like he was like initiating play with this other child with this real child uh real child gorilla and um And then like,
you know, they're like, the child was like, Yippee, friend.
And then he pushes the robot to the ground.
Friend!
And then he's like, oh.
And then, you know, the robot doesn't know how to get up.
So the child was like looking at the robot.
It was like, are you okay?
He's just like, hello?
And then, you know, the robot was just, you know, there like no movement and then so like like you know it literally gave the girl the baby child gorilla trauma because he's like oh my god did i did i kill him and he literally like looks at the robot and it just fucking runs away and he runs away and it was like i wasn't me it wasn't me but i'll show you guys the um i'll give you guys the link to that too i was just like jesus christ i love the comments too um gorilla robot spy i've been like i told you guys i was like i was like in this little rabbit hole of fucking robot spy because it's so interesting it's really um it's such it's such they're so interesting like the the whole premise of like sending a fucking a robot spy into like random places in the world and like infiltrating little like infiltrating like animal like um animal groups and stuff and you know they're just like he's he's just you know when he see the robot he's like yeah he's just a little special like
he's just like yeah he's just that's jerry he's just a little special he hasn't moved from that Like, you know, we don't want to, we don't want to make him feel weird.
Yeah, I like this.
Imagine asking the new kid at school to play with you.
And he suddenly falls down and dies.
Nobody.
BBC Mix Gorilla Baby thinks he killed a brother.
Let me see if I can grab a screenshot.
Oh, yeah, here.
And he's fam- I forgot, okay, the best part is that the robot gorilla, after he pushes him, he- he does the family guy pose.
That's the- what do I mean by that?
So stupid.
He actually does the fucking-
Quote.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
gorillas beat their chest it's fine but when i'm being like i'm the bad i guess you gotta go in the forest and live with the gorilla's kill thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um but yeah no like that baby gorilla freaked the fuck out because he thought he actually killed another gorilla um um burnout well thank you for the 10 gift and chips thank you thank you i really appreciate it but yeah no that's like the little rabbit hole that was in last night I think I remember talking about this before it,
but it's crazy that the sounds you hear from these like nature documentaries and clips, they're not real.
I don't know if you guys know that.
I talked, I remember talking about it before on stream, but for those who didn't watch that stream, they actually like manufacture the sounds like the folly, like, you know, like folly sound aside.
where they get this like where they get it they get a guy and they just fucking i don't know um hit some on the floor yeah like they're not real so if i i know i it's always every time i listen to like the sound design like the sound from the it sounds like it comes from the fucking clips um but because they're like the people who are filming these you know not from the spy cameras they're filming from like hundreds of miles away and they just have a really really expensive camera that they zoom in because their whole thing is that you're not supposed to you're not supposed to interrupt like you're not supposed to interfere with nature even if you see like a fucking child dying you're not supposed to ruin the like you're not supposed to interfere so because of that obviously the camera can actually pick up the sounds um of what they're uh like what it's actually happening so so they have to add like fake sound effects and everything So,
you know, if you hear like gorillas being like You hear like the The grass and the forest moving and stuff And on these clips, they're not real It's just some guy fucking getting a bunch Of leaves and being like
That's what you're hearing You're not actually hearing the gorillas Walking around in the forest It's literally some guy being like With his bunch of some fucking leaves In a sound booth Yeah, it's so interesting I remember watching a I always remember watching a clip about that being like oh yeah no you really think like this close-up video we have of like of these ants working and I'm do you really think that we have like some guy like walking up to the ants and putting like a sound booth like like like on those boom microphones you know like like a microphone boom microphone on these ants like really fucking tiny microphone while while we're documenting these goddamn ads and stuff uh the ad side yeah can you guys clip on these ad size microphones real quick we're trying to we're trying to make a documentary about you guys um um man i thought that was super interesting and i was like i was just binge watching a couple of these videos there's one where There's one with a robot puppy,
like there was a robot wolf puppy, a wolf cub, and then the mom saw it and she's like, that ain't right.
And she like kidnapped it and threw it.
And like she kidnapped it and she's like, children, get away from him.
He ain't right.
And like she grabbed the robot cub, the robot wolf cub and like took it like, I don't know, five miles away and then like threw it away and was like, don't come back.
yeah she was like skinwalker get away from the kids like i was like jesus christ and then the guy was like this was the last thing the robot the spy film because the wolf also broke the camera too and i'm like damn that's let's be like hundreds of thousands of dollars to to build that fucking spy camera because it has to be you know obviously like it's a robot too so like you have to be able to control it from far away so there's like the debutante was like this was the last thing the robot spy was able to film anyway hi hi bro mania I'm super excited to check it out usually you know I don't really play demos I wait until the uh the full release day of a game but I've actually have been of this game for a while because it was so interesting i saw it like i think i remember i started seeing it on twitter and i've always been very interested in alice and wonderland and um like you know the other stories like you know through the um i think the other ones like through the looking glass oh
it is a through the looking guy last um i want to make sure um yeah so yeah it's through the looking glass um but i've always been very interested in uh um in Lewis Carroll stories um in this world and I remember like one of my first uh games I played uh was Alice uh was out like American McGee's Alice and I remember going to like the EA what's it called uh GameStop or is GameStop the American one or is it EA Games it's EA Games the no not EB games EB Games is a Canadian version of yeah EB Games is the Canadian version of GameStop and I remember every time I go to games they would have these little like um cutout boards of uh American McGee's Alice of the Cheshire cat and um and like other stuff it was always there so I always but I was too young to play the game because you know I was a fucking child and I but like it interested me I was very like you know I was still like a scary cat but I've always seen those cutouts of um American Big E's Alice and also like you know the the the PC
boxes of it and I've always wanted to play it and you know like recently I think like two years ago I was able to play on stream for you guys um but the concept of it um was always like so intriguing because like you know it's like a dark take of Alice in Wonderland and and then another adaptation that's what drew me into this like like with Wonderland and everything was there were two games on Newgrounds that was very popular at that time um I think they made more but I'm not too sure but I'm playing two of them and it was like who like I think it was like it was like a murder mystery uh and you were trying to figure out like who killed the white rabbit um and you're playing as like yeah it was Alice Alice is dead because um and i remember like also white rabbit was also dead because you found his body later on but it was alice is dead and it was i've always loved that game because like the art style and the story was just so interesting and i remember playing it on newgrounds um a
lot back then and um because like it was i i don't know it was just something about that story and like i always played a lot of new ground games but the Alice's Dead series was always like stuck in my mind as one of my favorite new ground games I played growing up um so there's just something about like these takes on Wonderland and like how like especially if it's like dark takes on Wonderland because you can do so much about it because Wonderland is like basically like the imaginations of Alice of a child so it's like you know it can be anything it's Wonderland um also but But fuck Tim Burton's version of Allison.
That one I fucking didn't understand.
It's crazy because like, Allison Wonderland is all about like nonsensical things and like things supposed to not make sense.
But like Tim Burton's version of Wonderland, like I don't even, I don't know.
Like, yes, yes, it's Wonderland's all about things not making sense.
But that shit, that is just, I don't know.
That one was just too wild, too wild for me.
I don't understand why people are like, oh yeah, Timmeray is one of those.
So it's not, I don't think it's that good.
I personally, I don't even like the concept and the, because it was, the colors were, the cinematography and the color correction was really weird too.
And then like, you know, Johnny Depp, he's a good actor.
But him as the, I remember when he started dancing.
in his shoes I'm like what the fuck is he doing like yeah I get it he's a mad hatter but what why is he dancing why is he why is he tap dancing I don't understand where is my fucking tea party where is it why is my mad hatter tap dancing for me right now um but I I never fucking that was like the one the only version the only adaptation of Wonderland that I just did not like it was and then they're like it's not called Wonderland it's actually Underland and I'm like bro what the fuck you had one job and you can't even get the fucking name right like yeah they're like yeah Alice misheard the name um um the name of the of the world it's called underland not wonderland and i'm like what i thought that one was really dumb but for those who do like the movie um you know it's all preferences for me i just i just didn't like understand the plot very well because it was all for me it felt like it was all over the place and um and um and it it was just so it was hard for me to follow along to
the movie because i know it's all about nonsensical things but even then i was like even if it is a nonsensical i still would like to be able to follow the apply of what's going on as well as the dialogue um but yeah no i like all the other adaptations too i like the alice american mcgee's alice oh yeah by the way american mcgee had like a breakdown on twitter earlier because he was like um because um they were trying to make the third um um,
that's a third game for the, um, the Alice series.
Um, but then like EA game canceled it because they're like, that's too much money, bro.
Like your madness return didn't even make that much.
Um, and then he had a breakdown on Twitter because like people keep posting like, uh, gifts or like aesthetic gifts of, um, Alice make like, of American McGee's Alice.
And he was like, Where were you guys when we needed you?
I'm like, bro, bro, you gotta move on, bro.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, bro.
You gotta move on.
Blaming the fans is not the right move, man.
Yeah, he had like a, he had like, he wrote like a fucking, I think it was like six paragraphs.
Oh, yeah, girl, I'm sorry.
I was 11.
I didn't have income.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was too, it was just too far ahead.
It was too far ahead of his time, bro.
Like, you got, you had to make the game when Hot Topic was more hot.
Like, honestly, if he made the game and had a brand deal with Hot Topic, he could have had his third game, honestly.
From merch alone, it would have funded that shit.
um he just it was just the wrong game at the wrong time he really needed hot topic to be involved like if invader zim was able to be revived because hot topic is was selling their fucking 100th collaboration from invader zim after the show had ended for like 20 plus years then like honestly it would have worked out for him like that literally brought back invader Zim because people were still buying Invader Zim merch at Hot Topic.
But yeah, no, I'm super interested.
Like I said, I was following the development of this game for a while now, and the concept seems very interesting.
So I'm really looking forward to playing the demo today.
It is a very short demo, but after that I do have a lot of stuff to do after the stream.
so this may or may not just be like under two hours um just to give you guys a little warning and um but yeah let's go check it out I don't really know much about like the story itself um but I just saw like you know I saw the little trailer and it's like it just it just like hooked me in because the trailer seemed like really cool um and the art style too I love this artist art style
is alive today or any of my sound guys are alive
all right let's look at settings all right dark fast dialogue speed just in case um uh let's see ambience resolution high okay i want it oh i want the hd quality also like that it's all hand drawn too that's what you know also they do have a kickstart i don't know if it's funding is still going on
yeah the art looks great i want to play alice's dead again but it was made in flash so i don't even know if like it still exists or anything
get up okay don't tell me what to do you're not my mom
oh my head goodness did i fall from all the way up here that's got to be at least 100 meters a thousand actually how am i not dead maybe i shouldn't i put it on high this is like how am i lagging this is 2d oh i've landed on a tea table it must have broken my fall How peculiar!
It is an odd place to have tea though, isn't it?
At the bottom of a hole?
It's quite strange.
Oh, good god.
My head!
I think I must have bashed it on the way down.
I can't seem to remember how I got here.
Well, usually when I can't remember how I arrived somewhere, it's because I am dreaming.
so you must be dreaming again oh i know you're dreaming again alice though usually i wake up before i hit the ground i never struck around after speaking of alice the only good thing i like about the tim burns alice in wonderland movie is that they brought back avriel levine like i actually i love her song alice
i love that song that's actually in my phone right um It's on my...
I actually bought the album just for Averell Levine.
Fun shop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alice's Dead has a Steam version.
It does.
It's coming on 2026.
Also, I'm a huge fan of Twisted Fairy Tales.
And Habromania and the animatics are so fantastic.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, really?
Oh my God.
I'm so excited.
I'm so excited for that.
Like I said, I've always loved the Alice's Dead game series.
series.
It was so interesting.
The art style and the story itself.
I guess I should try to wake up.
Slap myself.
No, I feel like pinching does more because you don't actually slap yourself hard.
Hmm, well, that didn't work.
I suppose I should try again harder.
Pinch harder.
That's right.
Hurt yourself.
Ouch, Ouch, ouch.
It's not working.
Oh, dear.
I'm not dreaming, am I?
how did I get how did I get here and where is here how am I still alive after such a very long fall never accept reality oh Alice your head is just full of questions isn't it come on now let's try and unravel this I suppose the first thing I should find out is where am I I do remember how to walk at least let's on such wobbly knees okay maybe oh that's the inventory chapter one in the fall all right maybe oh wait i can't do oh there you go okay i will say i like that oh oh tarot cards with ancient pages deaf and the human i it is very creative but also i do not like the font for the settings because I got so confused.
Okay, maybe not high.
Maybe I isn't it.
Because I'm like lagging.
Okay, there we go.
I was like lagging a little bit.
All right.
What an odd place for a table.
I wonder who set this up.
You know what this reminds me of?
This gameplay reminds me of...
Was it Fran?
Um, the one where she's like...
Hello, little...
Hello, Dad.
Um, I think that's right.
The clock must be broken.
Awesome.
Who put a clock on the wall of a cable?
What was the game?
Yeah, Frambeau?
That's what it reminds me of right now.
I think I see some light peeking through here.
Yeah, the little girl.
Hello.
I'll shred myself to ribbons if I try to climb through all the thorns.
Okay, I guess we go left side.
So we can't go anywhere here.
Oh, no.
What can we do?
I know, but I'm just stuck.
Oh, wait, there's this.
What's under here?
What is under here?
Oh, wait, there's scissors.
Oh, what a pretty pair of scissors.
I should like to keep them, I think.
The fact that all of this is hand-drawn is insane.
That's so much work.
I cut the thorns.
My shiny pair of scissors shouldn't make quick work of this.
There we are.
Nicely done.
Snip, snip.
Yeah, her walk.
She's, like, shredding.
You know what this reminds me of?
That, um, the Russian walk song where it's, like, like, the three guys shredding along.
That one's in Ryan's...
Yeah, the power walk, yeah.
Pretty prickly little thing, aren't you?
Yeah, the lives...
Yeah, the lives he walk?
Yeah, that one's in Ryan's ear.
She's got confidence.
She got style.
Goodness, it's a...
It's a skeleton.
Oh, what's in there?
Is that a spider?
well that's the most horrifying thing i've ever seen oh dear i don't do well with dead bodies i'm afraid poor skeleton what happened to you did you get stuck here as well you certainly look like you've been down here for a while i suppose that doesn't promote very well for me
drat this way is blocked i could try scaling it maybe though in this dress and considering my I'm not sure that'll get me anywhere.
Is there anything else around here?
Oh, he has a bag.
Is this your bag, Mr. Skeleton?
Or Miss Skeleton?
I can say out of way, I suppose.
I should quite like to take a peek inside your bag if you don't mind.
Yorke's dead.
It's a book.
No, a journal.
Oh, were you a writer?
I'm a bit snoopy, I'm afraid.
I might give it a read.
No one will know him.
He's dead anyway.
empty journal journals are meant to be written in if you won't use it i will i can use this to keep my head on strike keep things sorted and organized oh i do hope i remember things soon worst case if someone finds my skeleton here they'll at least know who i knew i was remember my head hurts remember your past what could i use this journal for him oh she's an artist oh that's cute if you're reading this i might it's a good thing i can read cursive i might be dead in the bottom of a hole and you found this near my decaying corpse if so hello my name is alice i'm 19 years old and that's just about all i can remember about myself at the moment i've fallen quite a long way down and i think i must have hit my head pretty handwriting of course she's british hopefully she's a rich british girl too hopefully no important bits are damaged aside from the whole memory thing which i suppose is an important bit but i can worry about After I got it out of here,
whatever here is.
Okay.
Oh, I can overwrite it.
There's a Cheshaw cat.
Hello, cat.
Whoa.
Cat?
Oh, thank you, cat.
What was that?
Let me grab this.
Yoink.
That's a bit sad seeing as you're dead.
Your ring is very shiny, still.
Sicky fingers, Alice.
No, but, yeah, see?
That's right, girl.
It's okay if they're dead.
What is he gonna do?
What is he gonna do with the ring, guys?
If anything, I'm giving it life again.
Instead of letting it rot.
If this necklace's real, it must be ridiculous, expensive.
Yoink, my necklace now.
She's very beautiful and very nude.
Ha ha ha.
That's a bit ironic, isn't it?
What?
Oh, oh, it's because she's Medusa.
And she's, like, stone right now.
What a pretty young lady.
And what pretty flowers.
Lady Justice.
I hate to be the business end of the axe.
Why do they always make old people look so unpleasant?
I've always found old women delightful.
Oh, wait, what's this?
It's a photograph of a fountain.
Hmm?
Where is this?
Oh, okay.
So I have to find the statue.
What the fuck?
Why are the rats down there?
Okay, so maybe I have to find that statue?
Can I go more here?
Oh, I can.
Oh.
Yeah, hag love.
I wonder if I have a mother.
Well, obviously I know how to have a mother.
Everyone has a mother.
I mean, in a specific sense.
I can't remember.
Oh, look.
That's a nipple.
But you guys, oh, it's right here.
I hope you two.
It's okay.
I saw other people playing Habermania, and so I'm sure it'd be fine.
Censor that.
Okay.
So I have to, I think I just have to give the knife to Medusa, and I'll open the door.
There too.
I'm like a 14-year-old boy.
Oh, yoink, mine now.
This is the kind of basket I used to go picnicking with.
Yoink, mine now.
Yoink.
Wait, that's as close as I can get.
What do you mean?
I might not have anything else?
Oh, look at all these items I found.
I'm going to suspiciously shatter for being off the corpse.
See, till death do us part.
He's dead.
He doesn't need it anymore.
There's a stream of light coming from above.
It looks like a way out.
Now if I could just figure out how to get up there.
Oh, is that a gap?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Well, I could just jump over that.
That can't be too.
Oh, no.
It's pretty far.
Never mind.
It's some sort of bucket water elevator system.
It's not moving, though, obviously.
I didn't see the whole gamers don't look up down or up.
Okay.
Okay, we can't do anything.
Oh, it's covered in thorns?
I don't know what to do.
Snip, snip.
There you go.
Alright, up you go, little guy.
What?
I thought I could make it work.
Yeah, me too.
I thought so, too.
Oh, is that the cat?
Cat!
Is that you?
Mercy, that's not a rubble.
I could get crushed.
What a miserable looking clown.
thing it's up here oh this way there is anything else here oh hello crow hello miss raven that's quite a lovely nest you have here the raven blinks in a flattered sort of way also sound guy is everything okay oh there's a it's a bird'sness there's a bunch of sparkly bits and bobs in it okay so i have to what if i give him the ring you want the ring okay but it's shiny what
do you want i need the vase later for the medusa for the statue all right let me check my food order because they said it was going to come around this time so i want to be sure okay in seven minutes all right i just gotta be aware how are this old thing still works
Oh, what a pretty handheld mirror.
Gosh, my reflection sure looks worse for wear.
Cheer him up, Mirror Alex.
We'll get through this.
Yoink, my mirror now.
Anything in here?
Is this where...
Oh, hello there, little rat.
Oh, he dropped the coin.
It's hard-earned money.
My hard-earned money.
Was that rat wearing clothes or am I mad?
We're all mad here, Alice.
Let's go down.
Let's go.
How come the rat wears clothes, but the crow doesn't?
Our horn earned money now.
Not that money would do me any good here, but it surely is.
Wait, would the crow want my money?
The crow, I earned this for you.
Obviously, a shiny coin won't be...
I don't fucking know.
Crows like shiny things.
Don't kink shame the crow.
There's nothing else here then.
I don't know who was more frightened.
Me or the rat.
No, I found it fair and square.
He dropped.
He could have came back for it, but he didn't.
Poor dolly.
Down here all by yourself.
Where's your mama, baby?
unpleasant you want this baby how about this baby that didn't work let's put the baby doll away oh what about the basket there's like twigs in it would you consider moving your nest into this wicker basket instead of that pitcher oh there were branches in there but isn't convinced you'll have to sweeten the deal yes i know it's a bit drab i suppose i could dress it up for you The raven is unreadable.
I'll take that as a yes.
How the fuck do I?
Oh, I can combine it.
Can I combine that?
Oh, I did.
Oh, I'm making it shiny.
Here.
I put a nice shiny thing on it.
But is it moving?
Oh my god, you're so greedy.
What the fuck are you gonna...
Your old nest wasn't even shiny anyway.
All right.
How about this?
Now it has a neck.
Now it has bling on it.
Is this alright?
But it isn't moving.
I think give you the ring too?
What the fuck won't you?
You steal shit then for your fucking nest.
Okay.
Here you go.
His greed.
Her greed sickens me.
That should be enough, I think.
I put a lot of nice shiny things on it.
If I were a bird, I sure like to live in a nest like this.
Like, what happened to your old nest?
Your old nest had, like, you could just transfer your fucking old nest here.
Oh, for me?
A feather.
Wow.
Thank you very much, Miss Raven.
It's like she gave me a lock of her hair.
Which is definitely not.
Oh, wait, never mind.
Is there, like, one strand of her hair?
And be like, thank you for this $500,000 net.
Here's a strand of my hair.
A picture.
I wonder where I can use it.
Okay.
So it's one of the...
I assume it's the Medusa statue?
Because she was holding...
something.
The art of the deal.
I think the crow was a better negotiator than me.
I was gonna say I'm a child, but then this Alice is actually 19, so I'm just fucking stupid, I guess.
Or her, maybe?
yeah I think it's her wait it's not it looked like she was supposed to carry it
who would be the one that carries it young adults windowed by local bird I thought it was her she looked like she could carry it from with that hand but I guess not.
What?
I don't know where the fuck that statue is.
Oh, wait.
There are snakes.
I just noticed the snakes.
There you go.
There she is.
You're free now.
We all...
We all, guys, it was...
We all know she was dead before we got here, right?
The statue had no head when I got here, guys.
Well, getting her head cut off is a trophy thing, I mean.
Guys, guys, it wasn't me.
Guys, it wasn't me.
It could have been anyone else, but it wasn't me.
They'll give it to him.
I assume.
Aw, but he's headless.
No head?
She had no head when I got here, guys.
What the fuck do I do with this?
Statue head.
I don't know where to put this.
Justice?
It could have been any one of us!
You have no proof it was me!
That's the title's new...
Is it the moon cycle?
It's this one.
But, like, I don't know what to give her.
Maybe a rose?
They're a pretty flower or a pretty statue.
I knew it.
Okay.
So I got one of the symbols to start glowing.
Oh, okay.
What would the old lady want?
A feather?
What would she want?
Oh, food here.
Alright.
What does the old...
Oh, I feel like it's the apple, but I can't get across.
It has to be the apple, right?
Yeah, because she's like the...
The...
What was it called?
The crazy old lady from Snow White.
Not the wicked witch.
That's from Wizard of Oz.
I don't remember what it was called.
Okay, what would she want?
Would you want a baby?
Oh, here you go, Miss Statue.
I found a baby for you.
You want a trash baby?
The Evil Queen.
Yeah, but she had a name when she turned into the old lady.
It's, you know what?
There's another one.
Only one symbol left, and then, well...
I actually don't know exactly what this is doing.
But it's doing something, and that's better than nothing, I suppose.
Here you go.
Here's a trash baby.
Was it the crone?
How the fuck do I get the apple?
How do I get across?
Instruction's unclear.
Yeah, I can't make this move.
Oh, wait.
There's a vine that I could grab.
Yeah.
Garden hose on a headless snake.
Oh, wait, what?
I can bind this.
Oh!
And I can use this to grab the apple.
Wait, okay, never mind.
Let's put this fake snake away.
Never mind.
Apparently I can't use it.
Huh.
What can I do with a fake snake?
There's nothing I can do here.
I thought I could use it as a grapple.
Maybe like...
As I'm looking.
I'm looking as hard as I can look.
What the fuck do I...
Does the old lady want a fake snake?
I would assume like the old lady would want a...
Yeah, let's see.
Why would I use a fake snake here?
It's very beautiful and very nude.
I'm so... I don't know.
I don't know what statue would mean a fake-ass snake.
Does the headless want a snake?
I already... I thought I already finished her job.
Yeah, see?
Don't be daft.
The fake snake won't work here.
Wait, can I, like, scare the...
Oh, maybe the headless guy?
He doesn't have a brain.
It didn't work.
Did I get everything on the other side?
Let me see if I missed anything.
No, I didn't miss anything.
That's weird.
What the fuck do I mean?
Yeah, I tried it on all these statues.
I tried it on her, too.
There's no other items.
What am I supposed to do?
Spook the bird?
Because I want... I need to get to...
Yeah.
I was going to say, do I scare the bird or some shit?
Am I going to be that type of person?
I am that type of.
Oh, shit.
That's okay.
I didn't realize.
There was a plank here all along.
I thought it was like...
I don't know.
I thought it was part of the decoration.
There we go.
A bridge.
Very clever stuff.
I'm so clever, guys.
Now just try not to fall on it.
I'm not hungry, but this apple is too pretty to eat anyway.
God, I'm so goddamn clever, guys.
On me.
We have the apple.
Yeah, it blended into the background.
It didn't look like it was like something I picked up.
Would you like this apple, ma'am?
Yay!
The symbol is glowing now.
How very strange.
I did it.
Oh yeah, I'm British, so I'm used to taking everything without permission.
Hello, cat.
Oh, ma'am.
I got you your fucking vase or picture.
All right, go.
Is this what you need?
Oh.
That's not ominous at all.
Oh, would you look at that?
It's working again.
Where is the water coming from?
I wonder.
I suppose it's unimportant so long as it's working.
It's best not to think about things too hard sometimes.
All that water, because she can't keep any hold in her hand.
It all just slips through her fingers.
Just squeeze your fingers tighter.
Why is there holes in your finger you're trying to drink the water?
It gives me the heebie-jeebies, where heebie-jeebies are, it actually oh wait what's this a note is it say death and life were not enemies as the humans had always supposed just as there could be no warmth of day without the cool hand of night so too could there be no life without death life brought beginning mornings in light death brought ending sleep in peace and so it was for all time always and forever I love the soundtrack of this game It's just Gives a little bit of madness Like uneasiness,
I guess I wonder where this water flows to I'm trying to fucking head over, Alice But I seem to be not able to move from this area
Maybe like Does it go this way?
Oh, it's flowing through like the lake just a little bit of like uneasiness to like this oh yeah we did it
i'm gonna yoy you little man that's right oh oh okay i can ride the bucket mill yes i was gonna like fucking grab him magister thank you for the super chat thank you thank you love you turkey oh dear this isn't the surface is it i'm still underground oh it doesn't look like we're in Kansas.
Where is this place?
It looks nothing like the ruins from before.
Is that a house?
There's a car here.
Is this like a garbage pit?
Is anyone home, I wonder?
It's locked.
Knock, knock.
Hello, is somebody there?
I guess nobody's home.
Knock louder.
Let them know you're here.
Hello, anyone?
I've been in trouble, I think, if anyone is Here, hello, bang on that door, Alice.
Anyone kick that door open?
You have rights.
I don't think I should even bother.
I'm rather weak, unfortunately.
Coward.
You gotta show Wonderland whose boss?
Assert your dominance, exactly.
Break the window.
I don't like this painting much.
Oh, another note.
What's this?
A bit ominous.
FBI open up.
Life sowed the seeds of the living, and when the time came, death harvested, he craved cleaved their souls from their flesh and blood and teeth, and brought them to the after.
He will leave them there because their souls did not belong to them.
Death did not belong to anyone or anywhere, and no one and nothing belonged.
to him.
All deaf knew was taken.
There's so much taking to be done.
Are these my parents?
She doesn't look very happy.
They're very attractive couple.
Oh?
Oh, there's a book.
The complete works of Edgar Allan Poe.
Hmm.
What a sad poem.
That's me!
Be that word, our sign of painting bird parting bird are freeing i streaked go thee back into the tempest and the knights okay it's just agar allen poem you guys all know this poem nevermore okay i don't think there's anything else here uh broken bond thank you magenta super thank you thank you it's oh a fucking course is nevermore it's always nevermore That's cute.
I'm pretty sure he's like written like other stuff, but we'll almost just remember the Raven poem.
Here's an idea for the next playthrough after Batman.
Halo 2 is the easiest Halo deuce.
I shall only take about two to three streams to finish.
It'll also be funny since one of the skulls, it's really funny.
Thank you for the jump to super.
Thank you.
I was thinking about what playthrough.
It really depends on how I feel after like a playthrough on like what I want to do next afterwards.
But yeah, thank you.
I'll think about um we'll see how it goes after Batman what else can I do here oh there's a key oh it's someone's key oh hey I found that key first I'm here for the I'm here representing the British Museum I hate that quite a lot God help me what am I supposed to do he just took it
Oh.
Wait, the music changed.
Do you guys notice that?
Oh!
It got a little slower.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
I actually don't know what to do here.
Am I supposed to combine this?
No?
Hmm.
Wait, did the creepy rabbit have the key?
I wasn't looking at the painting.
Oh, you had to be super observant.
Oh, he did!
That's the key.
He didn't have that before, did he?
Oh, I don't like that.
I actually had goosebumps, the fact that the rabbit took the key.
How did I even... Well, in any case, I can have the key now.
Alright.
Is that nice of him?
He helped me bring the key closer.
I guess.
He was trying to be helpful, right?
Yeah, it was pretty unsettling.
Oh, butterfingers.
Let's try this again.
Oh.
Oh, is that the Cheshire cat?
Hello.
You look a bit lost.
Jeez.
I was not expecting that that line from Alice Jesus Christ a talking cat I mean to be I would to be Alice I would react the same to if a rat suddenly decided to fucking talk to me He's like I'm a proper British girl Jesus Christ a fucking talking cat
Jesus Christ a talking girl That's a bit rude of a greeting don't you think?
I It's like, oh, they find...
A talking cat, Alice said calmly.
Goodness, we're on Earth, did you?
My God, you're a talking cat.
I believe that's been well established, yes?
Jesus, Jesus, Joseph, and Mary.
You're...
Are you some sort of...
Some sort of radio toy or something?
Aren't these the only options?
Radio toy or something?
something huh in that case i suppose i would be a something yeah she's like sorry i'm half hours oh my gosh now you've done it alice you've hit your head and now you're talking to cats just like aunt edith no not aunt edith the fucking crazy cat lady your aunt edith is a cat oh sorry no i mean she talks to cats but she's loony and so am i i guess ever since we took her to the hospital and you know got the ice pick in there hasn't been the same mr cat can you help me so you seem shocked certainly you've seen a cat before not a talking one oh yes of course but not well i can't say i've heard one speak Really?
I found most cats quite verbose.
Mimi, you just don't want to talk to you.
Well, they meow at me, but I obviously don't understand them.
But you speak English.
I'm also fluent in German.
Oh, because it's like...
They're like talking about the grim tales, right?
Um, okay.
I think I might be hallucinating.
I hit my head.
Oh, it might be a concussion.
Yes, I saw.
That was quite the fall.
And nobody's fallen down here in the wild.
You saw?
Have you been watching me?
Oh, sure.
You're quite clever, Alice.
Getting that fountain working again.
The last one just fiddled with those statues for a while and then gave up.
Well, I...
Wait, sorry.
how do you know my name you fucking stalker because you look like an alice oh that's not creepy at all because that's what you are aren't you an alice what does that mean how exactly does an alice look stranger danger alice well you don't look like any old alice you look perfectly like yourself And since you happen to be an Alice,
you mean It means you look rather like an Alice After all, how else would you look?
I'm terribly confused, sir Well then, oh, which is it?
Oh my gosh, she's getting typecasted Magister, thank you, a super chat, thank you, thank you You're either confused or you're an Alice Which one?
I mean, I could be both I'm both, I'm supposed I'm a very confused Alice at the moment sorry i'm just a little overwhelmed right now so much has happened since i woke up and it's all just a bit much you know if you'd help just help me get my head sorted i would very much appreciate it is there a doctor here in wonderland uh sure very confused alice how can i help you so where are we do you know where we are we're here okay fucking smart ass well yes but where is that It's not where you were before.
Sorry, I hope this isn't rude, but I'm not asking what it is not.
I mean, I mean, what is this place?
Does it mean a name?
Yeah, so I can look it up on Google Maps or some shit.
That's a different place than you used to be.
A place where both happen to be at the moment.
Yeah, he's rage baiting.
I'm fucking getting my food if he's gonna rage bait me.
Give me a sec.
It's outside my door.
All right.
Just tell me where I am.
How did I get back to where I used to be?
The opposite of how you fell in, I should think.
Though it's usually a one-way trip.
See, that's the issue.
I can't remember anything from before.
I mean, I remember a few things.
Like, books and basic arithmetic.
And how to speak English, of course.
Like, what?
Is that math?
You fucking remember.
math?
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like, you don't remember your mom, but you remember basic arithmetic?
Bro.
Okay, there's a lot.
That concussion is a little bit too bad.
Oh, they didn't give me a fork!
Again!
How am I gonna eat my jolly spaghetti?
Alright.
She remembers me.
man let's go but all the helpful memories are just gone i don't know how i fell in i just remember waking up does that sort of thing usually happen to you forgetting things i mean how should i know if i usually forget things when i can't remember who i am okay but i know i'm an atlas and i know how what one plus one is whoa you're Alice well obviously but look do you know the way out of here or not sure it's in the house really well all right may I have the key back then I shouldn't think so no no why not does it belong to you I found it and then I accidentally dropped on the way over.
And then I found it.
So by your own very flimsy ethics, it's mine now, isn't it?
No, I found it first.
It's quite possible any number of people found the key before you did.
That didn't deter you from taking it.
Look, Mr. Cat!
I just really need to get out of here.
Can I please?
Please have the key.
Finders, keepers, and destroyed by facts and logic.
I am having an argument of a cat right now.
There's no facts or logic to this.
No.
Wait, that's it?
He just fucking says no?
I just need to get in.
No.
There's nothing behind that door for you yet.
But you just said that's the way out.
Yes, but not for you.
Not yet.
See, this is just a demo and the house and everything.
Everything after is all content that's not ready for you yet.
That's, there's early stuff, access stuff in there.
Early access, what are you?
Well, this is the demo.
It's only the first little bit of your story.
If you like to experience the rest, you'll have to wait for the next bit to be up.
So that's up to you.
Up to me.
What do you mean?
You want the rest of the game?
You can check out the Kickstarter.
currently up.
That's where you can gain access to the rest of the game as it's developed and released.
Oh my god, sir.
A Kickstarter?
And what would a Kickstarter be, Cat?
Yes, it's where they're hoping to get funded for a full game production.
You can find, oh, tell, wait, tell me more.
Can you tell me more about the Kickstarter?
How much story is left?
How much story is left for you?
10 out of 10 shilshire cap oh quite a lot this is only the first half of the first chapter and they're planning for 12 12 whole chapters and four endings the planning oh i must have been heading towards um the bad ending because of all the stuff i've been stealing 12 chapters and how will those come out one at a time and all at once Is it gonna be episodic cat?
The story will be divided into three acts with each act containing four chapters plus the different endings in the last act?
Quite right.
Oh my god.
About that Kickstarter.
So where do I follow the development?
How do I see updated on what's going on?
The Steam page and Kickstarter are a good starting point, but you can follow the creator.
youtube she regularly posts updates oh my god updates and things about me yes me and everyone else down here oh gosh all right so what should i do now if i can get in the house what should i do now you can look into the kickstarter for the games or the social or say yeah see if you miss anything okay okay yeah thank you miss thank you shill shire cat um so i guess we completed the demo wow we what a deal how the fuck did it take okay so i the cat was rage baiting all along guys i fucking
please like to say like and subscribe okay so i was like i didn't want to spoil myself because i wanted to know like you know how long and like playthroughs were like 40 minutes Plus.
There's no way.
Like, I fucking talked for, like, 40 minutes before I started the game.
How the fuck did it take?
Did people just not look?
Like, did they just not look around?
How were they stuck on this game?
Wait, ask him for the key?
Oh, I could.
Can I have the key?
Can I please have the key card, please?
How about this?
When we get to the real thing, I'll give it to you myself.
I'd really rather just have it now.
That would be nice, wouldn't it?
So, can you give it to me?
No.
Please?
Pretty, pretty, no.
I suppose if it's the only way to quell your insisting pestering, I can give it to you.
Really?
Thank you, Mr. Cap.
Be aware.
You may not encounter what you expect.
Alright, what's in here?
Is there going to be, like, some... Oh, wait, what the... Okay, I thought, like, I thought like, he got me the key and it broke the game because I was not walking there.
Alright.
Is there going to be some guy that just fucking runs up to me and eats me and is like the end thank you for playing it has to be death hundred percent it's just gonna be like like some like um i'll just be walking in the void or some shit yeah it's the greatest yeah
oh that's cute they have little like portraits of themselves too oh my god is that has been hotel yeah that's cute though i really enjoyed the little demo even though it's like um it was really short um i did the story what has been interesting so far and i love the little character designs as well as like the the puzzles you know um it's a very classic point and click adventure um and it did felt very nostalgic uh when i used to play these types of games on I don't know.
I think it's coming out next year, right?
Or is it?
It seems very interesting so far.
And it's a very, like, tiny studio.
It's coming up next year, right?
Or when does the Kickstarter say it's coming out?
Yeah, the Kickstarter is still...
I don't know.
I might back it, honestly.
It depends on the rewards.
Honestly, I hope it does have really nice rewards.
Let me check it out.
I'll check out the...
I'll link it to.
Since it's been, I think, and the soundtrack.
I like how the soundtrack also sort of changes when it gets more creepy.
I'll link the Kickstarter real quick for you guys.
Here's the Kickstarter.
Oh my god, it already, not 69, it already, like, passed its initial goal.
What even are, what are some of the, oh, 50k expanded, more outfits, cutscene, extra ending.
already got all its stretch clothes and everything too um characters the white rabbit the hair there's like it tells gives you background on some of the characters oh my god there's fucking rat town it's fucking oh my god there's so many there's a pasture rat okay i like i like how they made mickey mickey and minnie and i guess which one guys um oh shit i don't think i can say can i save this asset i don't wait save image i'm gonna say i can show this image guess guys guess which one is inspired by mickey and minnie oh i can't i can't show it but if you scroll down you can sort of see yeah you can see they're like like there's like um uh character concept art of like um the uh what would it call it the The rich mice.
The rich rats.
The, what are they called?
Like the rich British people?
They're called Michael Mouse and Mavirna.
Minerva.
Yeah, the wealthiest of rats.
Um.
I want to look at the.
The fucking.
The Erystorats.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, guys, if you scroll down, you can see the main cast of Habromania.
And guess which one looks like a Tumblr sexy man?
I can tell that one guy in this game is going to be the designated Tumblr sexy man.
It's right there.
But I just realized I could have just snipped it.
which one could it be he has everything the man had he has everything that they want a man in a suit that's it the criteria is very low as long as the man is in the suit he has become the tumblr sexy man yeah he actually does look like lilywanka you're right it does look like him um all right so the game oh has button pins stickers oh i actually really like the card deck oh wait the limitation queen of heart i don't know if i want the bust but i do like i think the the um the bonus items that you can get i do like the um the illustrated poker card deck i'll back it from that the central merch kit for anyone you'll get your very own deck of custom printed poker cards and a matching box the digital download of the art book four prints five stickers five button pins and the design and more i'll grab that which one's all gone oh the early bird shit is all gone already our most comprehensive ultra very cool and deluxe harmonia package includes everything as as well as the exclusive sculpted
resin 3d bus your portrait no the portrait in the game it's all god only 25 people could get it oh my god they are they also took away the oh i okay more people get hardbromania mpcs i'm so sad i actually i would have got that i could have made i could have made a dokey braid i could have made a dokey braid oh i should have been on top of this that would have i'd be like hello if i give you a thousand oh wait wait guys guys you're thinking i dm the creator and be like if i give you a thousand can i also get a hybromania mpc if because you think should i shoot my shot should i should i shoot my shot guys I can be in I can be in hypomania just bribe harder exactly if I bribe harder.
Do you think they'll take my bribe?
Do you think I'll do it?
Okay, okay, I'll do it after I eat my jolly spaghetti at her stop I feel like I cannot what they'll have their own unique NPC dialogue you guys you'll work with the creator Don't keep it an NPC fun.
You know, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If all fails, just throw money at the problem.
That always works.
Anyway, guys, I have a lot of stuff to do later today.
I'm sorry, it is a very, uh, I'll even voice acting.
I don't think like, okay, I don't think there's voice acting.
Everyone was literally talking in piano, guys.
I don't think that works.
You're like, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
beep I'll supply my own beeps like I'll be the only one that be like beep beep boop pop beep and everyone's just talking in piano and you'll be the only one voice acted the piano talkers and one and one beep pop um anyway guys I know it's a very short stream but I should have a lot to do um later today um but I hope you guys enjoyed today's playthrough is a lot different from the games I usually but I honestly I do love point-and-click adventures um because I used to play a lot of them like growing up I'm mostly on newgrounds though like I think point-and-click adventures were very popular on newground games and this honestly reminded me it reminded me of Alice is dead and reminded me of all like the classic point-and-click adventures back then um that I used to play like I remember you guys remember the Garfield um the Garfield point-and-click adventure where you're stuck in a haunted house like stuff like that or the Scooby or the Halloween ones too The Halloween ones from Cartoon
Network.
I used to play that a lot back then, growing up.
I never played Monkey Island, surprisingly, I think, because I was way too young for Monkey Island.
But anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I know someone said, like, oh, when we play Newgrounds and stuff, games the thing is it's so difficult because all the games that were on newgrounds we were ran off of flash so it's like you need like and like you know flash is fucking dead so so there's a lot of like dead games on newgrounds which fucking sucks because uh there's there is a lot of fun ones back uh on there and i'll see you guys later everyone bye bye